muy buenas tardes pues la conclusión
principal de este encuentro es que tanto
de manuel marco angela merkel como
volodymyr arts de lenski han pedido a
rusia el retiro de sus tropas desde la
frontera ucraniana precisamente con la
perspectiva con la esperanza de que sean
puedan imaginar esas tensiones que han
venido creciendo en estas últimas
semanas pues rusia ha venido desplegando
miles de militares a esa zona además de
misiles balísticos y tanques entre otros
francia y alemania han dicho que están
comprometidos en la defensa tanto de la
independencia como de la soberanía de
ucrania y han pedido además pues que se
respeten los acuerdos de paz que se
firmaron en minsk allá en 2015 tendría
que error está ocupando concretamente
francia en estos encuentros que están
buscando por supuesto como decíamos
bajar las tensiones entre rusia y
ucrania
así después a francia juega un rol clave
por eso el body mir selenski le pidió
hoy a maicon pero también a angela
merkel que le hagan un pronto una
reunión del formato de normandía cuál es
este formato bueno es una reunión en la
que ucranianos y rusos se sientan a
dialogar bajo la mediación o
franco-alemana este formato digamos
nació en 2014 cuando comenzó
precisamente este conflicto en esta
región del este de europa y francia ha
venido participando a lo largo de todo
este tiempo en eso cuando hubo la última
reunión de este tipo fue en diciembre de
2019 pero no se saldó por ningún tipo de
avance o de progreso a nivel político
concreto la esperanza desde el anzhí es
que si se vuelve a organizar esta
reunión dentro de muy poco tiempo pues
se pueda conseguir un alto al fuego que
sea determinante que sea perenne sobre
todo para la región de las bombas ahora
hay que tener en cuenta que francia
juega
digamos un papel importante allí ha
apoyado y lo está haciendo abiertamente
a ucrania pero no por eso digamos corta
los puentes de comunicación con rusia
porque esa es una de las estrategias que
ha tenido más combate
siempre abierto esa posibilidad de
diálogo con moscú